This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家近来如何？欢迎收听《艰难学步》，我是你们最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个节目探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都觉得不太安全但却真实坦诚的对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力并不意味着你需要这么做，收听《艰难学步》。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
锁定AHA电台应用、苹果播客，或在任何你获取播客的地方收听。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这个特定的检测结果两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《受困之爱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些困难，你就会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人的姿态在另一头出现。收听《2%》。也就是在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听“TWA percent”。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约定时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here. Back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we're diving into a topic that I think resonates with about every single one of us, and that is how to care less about what other people think about you. Let us be completely real and transparent here.
我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝，在Iheart radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里。又迎来新的一期节目，当然，我们要剖析二十几岁的心理学。今天，我们要深入探讨一个我认为能与我们每个人产生共鸣的话题，那就是如何少在意别人对你的看法。让我们在这里完全保持真实和透明。
This is a lot easier said than done. We all know that worrying about the opinions of others will rob us of our authenticity, It will make us less happy. It will, you know, disturb our peace of mind. And yet there is this little voice inside our heads whispering things like, what will they think of me? What if they don't like me? Is the world going to end?
这说起来容易做起来难。我们都知道，担心别人的看法会剥夺我们的真实自我，它会让我们不那么快乐。它会，你知道的，打扰我们的内心平静。然而，我们脑海深处总有个小声音在低语，比如：他们会怎么看我？如果他们不喜欢我怎么办？世界会毁灭吗？
Will this choice make me look good to others? And it's not our inner critic. It's something else. It's our inner need for approval. Our inner animal primal version of us who wants to belong. and not upset others. And the problem is that it can become a real mental barrier. If we let it dominate the choices we make in our 20s, our behavior, our decisions, and
这个选择会让我看起来在别人眼中很好吗？这不是我们的内在批判者。这是别的什么。是我们对认可的内在需求。是我们内心想要归属感、不想惹恼他人的动物本能版本。问题在于，它会变成真正的心理障碍。如果我们让它主导我们在二十几岁时做出的选择、我们的行为、我们的决定，以及
ultimately our lives, I think during this decade, it's quite a fragile time where we really are just trying to figure out so many big questions. And sometimes we rely too heavily on what other people think is best or what other people think we should be doing. And when we are fixated on these possible or actual judgments, it's like we have to hold up every life decision to a different light, under a different light, and think, how's this person going to see it? How about this person? Am I still going to have their approval? And this often happens before we do anything, even without us knowing. But deep down, oftentimes, we already know who we are.
最终我们的生活，我认为在这个十年里，这是一个相当脆弱的时期，我们真的只是在试图弄清楚许多重大问题。有时我们过分依赖别人认为什么是最好的，或者别人认为我们应该做什么。当我们全神贯注于这些可能或实际的评判时，就像我们必须把每一个生活决定都放在不同的光线下，在不同的光线下审视，然后想：这个人会怎么看？这个人呢？我还能得到他们的批准吗？这通常在我们做任何事情之前就发生了，甚至在我们不知情的情况下。但在内心深处，很多时候，我们其实已经知道自己是谁了。
We already know what we want. We just have to fight against this weirdly misplaced instinct to be validated by others before we truly are able to trust ourselves. And I really do think it comes down to a lack of self-trust. We don't trust that we know what's right. And we don't trust that we'll be able to survive the potential negative judgments of friends, of family members, of random strangers. So in this episode, I want us to really dig deep into the psychology of why. Why do we care so much in the first place? Where does this instinct come from?
我们已经知道自己想要什么。我们只是必须与这种奇怪的、错位的渴望得到他人验证的本能作斗争，然后才能真正相信自己。我真的认为这归根结底是缺乏对自己的信任。我们不相信自己知道什么是对的。我们不相信自己能够经受住朋友、家庭成员、随机陌生人潜在的负面评判。所以在这一期里，我想让我们真正深入探讨原因的心理学。为什么首先我们这么在意？这种本能从何而来？
And how does it impact our search for self-esteem, for purpose, for authenticity really, in our 20s? And most importantly, most importantly of all, how can we start letting go of this need for approval so that we can live the lives that we truly want? We're going to talk about evolutionary psychology, childhood experiences. I also share, of course, some practical tips to help you shift your focus inward, to trust your own judgment, and to really strengthen your sense of self as well as my famous rule of fives that I swear by. And hopefully by the end of this episode, you feel inspired, you feel equipped to prioritize your own opinion and to truly honor who you are without being weighed down by the noise. of others. Really, this is the episode that I wish I had when I was younger. All of this information
它又如何影响我们在二十几岁时对自尊、目标和真正的真实性的追求？最重要的是，最重要的一点是，我们如何开始放下对认可的需求，从而过上我们真正想要的生活？我们将讨论进化心理学、童年经历。当然，我还会分享一些实用的建议，帮助你将注意力转向内，相信自己的判断，真正增强你的自我意识以及我奉为圭臬的著名的“五人法则”。希望在本期节目的最后，你会感到受到鼓舞，感到自己有能力优先考虑自己的意见，真正尊重自我，而不被别人的噪音所压垮。真的，这就是我希望自己年轻时能听到的那一期节目。所有这些信息
is things that I've had to learn and that I wish I could tell a past version of myself, but now I get to tell you guys, which is honestly just as good. So without further ado, let's get into the psychology about why we care and how do care less about what other people think. So this has been on my mind quite a lot recently, and the reason being is because I I launched my new podcast mantra a couple of weeks ago. And for those of you who haven't listened to it yet, it's basically a weekly show where I dive into some kind of inspiring affirmation or reminder for you to bring with you throughout the week.
都是我不得不学习的东西，我希望自己能告诉过去的自己，但现在我可以告诉你们，说实话这也一样好。闲话少说，让我们进入关于我们为什么在意以及如何少在意别人看法的心理学。所以这件事最近一直在我的脑海里盘旋，原因是我在几周前推出了我的新播客《咒语（Mantra）》。对于那些还没听过的人来说，它基本上是一个每周播出的节目，我会在节目中深入探讨一些鼓舞人心的肯定语或提醒，供你在整周里随身携带。
So the one we did last week was I cultivate peace within. I embrace growth and change, that kind of thing. And it's just a place for me to kind of express wisdom and be a little bit more philosophical and a bit more grounding compared to the psychology of your 20s, which is more science-based. And before I announced that show and launched that show, I had this huge fear that so many people were going to turn around, look at me doing this and say, oh, we hate it. We hate that you're doing that. That's not what we want.
所以我们上周做的是：我培养内心的平静。我拥抱成长和变化，诸如此类。这只是一个让我表达智慧的地方，相比于《二十几岁心理学》那种更加基于科学的节目，这里会更具哲学性，也更让人踏步接地气。在我宣布并推出那个节目之前，我有一种巨大的恐惧，那就是很多人会转过身来，看著我做这件事然后说，哦，我们讨厌它。我们讨厌你这么做。这不是我们想要的。
Boo, like, just stick to what you know, stick to what you're good at. And it really got into my head. I was like, is this a good idea? Should I even be doing this? And the thing was, no one even knew that I was. Other than my team and my wonderful support network, no one who is a listener of the show who doesn't know me knew that I was putting this out.
嘘，就像，只坚持你懂的，坚持你擅长的。这真的钻进我的脑子里了。我在想：这是一个好主意吗？我甚至应该这样做吗？问题是，根本没人知道我在做。除了我的团队和极好的支持网络之外，没有一个听我节目、不认识我的人知道我在发布这个。
And yet I was putting words into their mouth and they were the words that I most feared, that I would be judged, that people wouldn't like it, that I would be criticized. And it got to the point where I was almost like, oh, this is just such a bad decision. like they already hate it without ever actually even having shown anyone. And it really got me thinking around how many opportunities and how many things in your life
然而，我却把话塞进他们的嘴里，而那些正是我最害怕的话：我会受到评判，人们会不喜欢它，我会受到批评。以至于我几乎在想：哦，这真是一个糟糕的决定。就像他们还没听过任何人展示，就已经开始讨厌它了。这真的让我开始思考，在你的生活中，有多少机会和事情
have you not done or have you stopped yourself from doing because you're imagining what other people think before they even have the chance to think it or say it. And that's really the conundrum that we find ourselves in a lot and it holds us back. Just having that experience made me realize how many other areas of my life, I have already been held back by other's opinions, real or imaginary, and how I wish that that hadn't been the case. Before we get into how to stop that from happening, I think we need to just know the basics, which is why. That's the million dollar question, right? Why does this happen? Why do we care? You could know what it's costing you, and you still can't ignore it. The reason this voice,
你没有做，或者你阻止自己去做，因为你在别人甚至还没机会去想或说之前，就在想象别人的想法。这确实是我们经常发现自己陷入的困境，它阻碍了我们的发展。仅仅有那次经历就让我意识到，在我生活的多少其他领域里，我已经因为别人的真实或想象的意见而受到阻碍，以及我是多么希望情况不是这样的。在我们讨论如何阻止这种情况发生之前，我想我们需要了解基础知识，也就是为什么。这就是那个价值百万的问题，对吧？为什么会这样？我们为什么要在意？你可能知道这让你付出了代价，但你仍然无法忽视它。这个原因声音，
the voice of others, the voice of some ambiguous hater or person, feel so omnipresent has two really important explanations. The first is a very evolutionary explanation. We are tribal creatures who previously relied on the approval and acceptance of others to survive. And so to make sure we aren't alienated from our social group, which would in the past have ensured immediate certain death, we've become very attuned to what other people think. And this part of us, it really originated and developed way before civilization was as large and expansive as it is today. It originated and evolved and developed when we did live in very small communities, where the opinion of your neighbor, the opinion of the person in the hot next door,
别人的声音，某个模棱两可的讨厌鬼或某个人的声音，感觉如此无处不在，有两个非常重要的解释。首先是非常进化的解释。我们是部落动物，以前依靠别人的批准和接受来生存。因此，为了确保我们不会被我们的社交群体疏远，这在过去将确保立即确定的死亡，我们对其他人的想法变得非常敏感。而我们这部分，它真正起源和发展的时间远远早于今天这样庞大和广阔的文明。它起源、演变和发展的时期是我们确实生活在非常小的社区里，在那些社区里，你的邻居的意见，隔壁热心人的意见，
was significant for your life. So those parts of the brain that are responsible for triggering our fear of rejection or of a They are part of what we call the old brain or the reptilian brain, which is why they feel so almost instantaneous. It's why they feel so out of our control because they are meant to function almost automatically. The other part of our brain that really plays a role in this is the frontal lobe. These two areas, they have taken a long time to evolve and a long time to take place and they have also been around. for many, many, many generations. And considering how rapidly society has grown
对你的生活至关重要。因此，大脑中负责触发我们对拒绝或恐慌的恐惧的那些部分。它们是我们所说的古脑或爬行动物脑的一部分，这就是为什么它们感觉几乎是瞬时的。这也是为什么它们感觉如此不受我们控制，因为它们注定要几乎自动运行。大脑中真正发挥作用的另一部分是额叶。这两个区域，它们花很长时间进化，花很长时间形成，而且它们也存在了
and our networks have expanded from maybe 50 people to literally hundreds of thousands that we can access online and how, you know, that's only been in the last 20 years, basically these old parts of our brain haven't caught up with the context and how easily it is to be judged at basically any given moment online and in a much, much larger society. How I explain it is that the old part of your brain
很多很多代了。考虑到社会增长的速度有多快，我们的网络已经从也许50人扩展到字面意义上我们可以在线访问的数十万，以及，你知道，那基本上只是在过去20年里发生的，大脑的这些古老部分基本上没有赶上环境，也没有赶上在在线的任何给定时刻以及在更大得多的社会中被评判是多么容易。我是如何解释的：你大脑的那一部分
that is used to caring about the judgments of others and being very socially attuned, that is like trying to run a complex computer game on the first ever MacBook. You know, the system is obviously going to get overwhelmed and that is your brain trying to manage this hyper-social modern context of a thousand opinions on, you know, a system that developed when that wasn't the case.
习惯于关心别人的判断并且高度社交敏锐，这就像试图在第一台MacBook上运行复杂的电脑游戏。你知道，系统显然会不堪重负，这就是你的大脑试图管理这种超社交的现代环境，在一个由于系统开发时并非如此而产生了一千种意见的环境中。
So the second explanation for why we care, which is very much a link to what we just spoke about, it's to do with our self-esteem and how our identity in part really is reliant on the opinions and approval of others. Even from a very young age, we sense and we know that if people like us, life will be easier.
因此，关于我们为什么在意的第二个解释，这与我们刚才谈到的内容密切相关，它与我们的自尊有关，以及我们的认同感在多大程度上确实依赖于其他人的意见和认可。甚至从很小的时候起，我们就感觉到并知道，如果人们喜欢我们，生活就会更容易。
And we will feel good about ourselves because people will be kind to us, They'll want to help us. They won't outright harm us. So it's in that way that sometimes our acknowledgement and our fear of other people's opinions is sometimes a protective mechanism. There have been studies showing that from as young as maybe two years old, we are aware that we are being evaluated by others. And by around five, we actually begin to change our behavior in certain circumstances
我们会对自己感觉良好，因为人们会对我好，他们会想帮助我们。他们不会直接伤害我们。所以在某种程度上，有时我们对其他人意见的承认和恐惧有时是一种保护机制。研究表明，从大约两岁开始，我们就意识到自己正在被其他人评估。到了五岁左右，我们实际上开始在某些情况下改变我们的行为
based on what we think others will like or will be favorable towards. So this interaction, this is called approval seeking behavior, wanting to be liked, wanting to be seen as good, wanting to be validated and rewarded by another person. In order for that process to kind of take place in order to seek approval, you have to firstly acknowledge that other people have opinions. And secondly, you have to be able to make a decision as to whether you want to let that opinion dictate your behavior based on what you think the outcome will be for you.
基于我们认为其他人会喜欢或会对其持赞成态度的内容。所以这种互动，这被称为寻求认可的行为，想要被人喜欢，想要被视为好人，想要得到另一个人的验证和奖励。为了让那个过程发生，为了寻求认可，你必须首先承认其他人有意见。其次，你必须能够根据你认为对你而言的结果，来决定是否让这种意见主导你的行为。
And when we become very obsessed with other people's opinions, implicitly, we believe that doing so is going to help us more than it will harm us. I don't think that's the case. I also don't think that it will come as a surprise that excessive approval-seeking behavior in adulthood is linked to early childhood experiences. particularly what we call adverse childhood experiences. So if you were highly criticized as a child, if you were neglected by those who were meant to love you most, you were ignored, you were bullied. Approval is something you want more than anything else
当我们变得非常痴迷于别人的意见时，潜意识里，我们相信这样做对我们的帮助会大于伤害。我认为事实并非如此。我也认为，成年后过度寻求认可的行为与早期童年经历有关，这应该不会让人感到惊讶。特别是我们所说的不良童年经历。因此，如果你在童年中受到高度批评，如果你被那些本该最爱你的人忽视，你被冷落，你被欺凌。认可成了你最渴望的东西
because you know what it feels like and how terrible it is to not have it. You know how cold and solitary and lonely it feels to not. be liked and to not be told that you're good. A 2021 paper actually that I found when researching this, it looked at bullying in particular and it linked childhood bullying to greater approval seeking behavior as adults and specifically a lot more people pleasing and self-sacrificing behavior as well. Approval seeking as an adult I should probably tell you what that looks like. It's basically what we would describe as caring too much about what other people think what other people think but it's not an inward process it becomes an outward process so you end up relying on others opinions to help you make
因为你知道那种感觉，以及没有它是多么糟糕。你知道不被人喜欢、没有被告知你很好的那种冰冷、孤立和孤独的感觉。我在研究这个时发现的一篇2021年的论文实际上探讨了欺凌，特别是将童年欺凌与成年后更大的寻求认可的行为联系起来，具体来说是更多的讨好和自我牺牲行为。作为成年人寻求认可，我或许应该告诉你那是什么样子的。这基本上就是我们所描述的过度关心别人的看法别人的看法，但它不是一个内向的过程，它变成了一个外向的过程，所以你最终依赖别人的意见来帮助你做出
life decisions so if you are left with a big decision about what you want to study where you want to move what job you want to take what to do in your friendships and your relationships you may be unable to come to that decision yourself you have to check with as many people as possible about what they think is right. Your actions also change based on how you think someone will react. You become, your emotions in particular about something become very much dictated by what someone else thinks first. You may find yourself rejecting opportunities and experiences that you really want because you worry whether others will approve and you might even feel ashamed or like you need to excessively explain yourself if someone questions or dislikes your work, your actions.
生活决定。因此，如果你留下来面临一个关于你想学什么、你想搬到哪里、你想接受什么工作、在你的友谊和关系中做什么的重大决定，你可能无法自己做出那个决定。你必须和尽可能多的人核对他们认为什么是对的。你的行为也会根据你认为某人会有什么反应而改变。你变得，特别是你对某事的情绪，很大程度上取决于别人的想法。你可能会发现自己拒绝了你真正想要的机会和体验，因为你担心别人是否会批准，如果有人质疑或不喜欢你的工作、你的行动，你甚至可能会感到羞耻或觉得需要过度解释。
your decisions, any of those things. All of this links back to letting the opinions of others dictate your life. I would also like to point out, and I've already mentioned this, that sometimes this is also born from a lack of self-trust. Basically, we are no longer able to provide ourselves with validation or approval. We don't trust our opinion on ourselves, so we require other people to be able to confirm or deny our worth. And, you know, I really wonder why we get to the point where we are willing to trust a stranger and what they think more than ourselves, more than someone that we have known our whole life, who knows everything about us more than anyone else.
你的决定，任何这些事情。所有这一切都追溯到让别人的意见主导你的生活。我还想指出，我已经提到过这一点，有时这也源于缺乏自我信任。基本上，我们不再能够为自己提供验证或认可。我们不信任自己对自己的看法，所以我们需要其他人来确认或否认我们的价值。而且，你知道，我真的很想知道为什么我们会落到这种地步，愿意相信一个陌生人及其想法，超过我们自己，超过一个我们认识了一生、比任何人都更了解我们一切的人。
At some point, though, you do have to make a choice. Would you rather people like you or would you rather like yourself? I think it gets to a point where this is really what it comes down to. And actually, it's bigger than that. It's would you rather actually live the life you want? Wouldn't you rather give yourself the space to figure out what's best for you without trying to fit into someone else's box? There was a quote I read the other day that I think captures this perfectly.
不过，在某个时刻，你确实必须做出选择。你是希望别人喜欢你，还是希望自己喜欢自己？我想到了某个时刻，这才是真正的关键所在。事实上，这比那更宏大。是你愿意真正过上自己想要的生活吗？难道你不想给自己空间去弄清楚什么对你最好，而不是试图塞进别人的盒子里吗？我前几天读到过一句话，我认为完美地捕捉到了这一点。
It said by being concerned about what other people think, we avoid the short-term pain of rejection or the possible loss of status in exchange for the long-term loss of missing out on a life truly worth living. So let's talk about what happens when we invest too heavily in other people's opinions at the expense of our own. The first thing we are likely to experience is a dependence on external validation, which will make it hard to do things purely for the joy of doing them or because we want to. In order to keep up our supply of external validation as well, we kind of become like
上面提到，由于过于在意别人的看法，我们用错失真正有价值的人生作为长期的代价，来换取拒绝带来的短期痛苦或地位可能受损的微小规避。所以我们来聊聊，当我们过度投入他人的意见而牺牲了自我时，会发生什么。我们可能最先经历的是对外部认同的依赖，这会让我们很难单纯为了快乐或出于自己的意愿去做好玩的事。为了维持外部认同的来源，我们甚至会变得像
addicts. So we might develop people pleasing tendencies and end up feeling very used, resentful, exhausted. We may avoid conflict or suppress our needs in order to maintain others' approval, despite feeling worse about ourselves in other areas of our life. This also, crucially, makes our self-worth incredibly unstable because the opinions of others, they aren't something that we can rely on. They're fickle. People change their minds all the time. Their approval of us is often based on what they want, not what's best for us. I think about this in the context as well of celebrities who go from being darlings to being hated overnight when public opinion turns because it is incredibly fickle. It is not something to be relied on. But also on a more individual level,
瘾君子一样。因此，我们可能会发展出取悦他人的倾向，最终感到自己被利用、充满怨恨、精疲力竭。为了维持别人的认可，我们可能会避免冲突或压抑自己的需求，尽管这会让我们对生活中其他地方的自己感觉更糟。更关键的是，这会使我们的自我价值变得极不稳定，因为别人的意见是我们无法依靠的。它们反复无常。人们随时都在改变主意。他们对我们的认可往往基于他们想要什么，而不是对我们最好的。我在名人的语境中也想到了这一点，当公众舆论转变时，他们在一夜之间从宠儿变成被人厌恶，因为这极其反复无常。这不是可以依赖的东西。但在更个人的层面上，
if you're not a celebrity. When people realize that you rely on their judgment and that you want them to like you, this can also be really in some ways used to manipulate you into saying yes, into overdoing, overgiving, just being and giving them too much of yourself at the expense of you. We also end up over-analyzing others' perceptions of us, and that can lead to really heightened anxiety,
如果你不是名人。当人们意识到你依赖他们的判断并且希望他们喜欢你时，从某种程度上说，这也可以被用来操纵你，让你说“好”，让你过度付出、过度给予，仅仅是为了他们而把过多的自己给了他们，从而牺牲了你自己。我们最终还会过度分析别人对我们的看法，这会导致高度的焦虑，
particularly in social settings. like caring about other people's opinions is a hallmark of social anxiety because we imagine there is this big spotlight on our every move and that, you know, one misstep will result in a disaster. And when other people's opinions become a fixation and a main worry, this also slowly erodes our authenticity because we want to be liked more than we want to honor ourselves. One of those things feels more important to us. and that can lead to a disconnect between your values, your beliefs, your preferences, your likes, and your behavior. I don't think I need to tell you that what you're left with is really nothing.
尤其是在社交场合中。就像在意别人的意见一样，这是社交焦虑的一个标志，因为我们想象有一道巨大的聚光灯照着我们的一举一动，你知道的，任何一个失误都会导致灾难。当别人的意见变成一种执念和主要的担忧时，这也慢慢侵蚀了我们的真实性，因为我们想要被喜欢胜过我们想要忠于自己。其中一件事对我们来说感觉更重要，这可能导致你的价值观、信仰、偏好、喜好与你的行为之间产生脱节。我想我不需要告诉你，你最后得到的其实什么都不是。
You just end up being an amalgamation of what everyone else wants you to be. So there is a distinct feeling of emptiness and a lack of fulfillment that comes along with this. There was a 2017 paper written about this called Authenticity. as a predictor of mental health, and it looked at 706 students, and it found that those who practiced authentic living, who could name five of their personal values, they reported being not as easily swayed by external influence. They were happier, they were more satisfied with their lives,
你最终只会成为每个人都希望你成为的混合体。因此，伴随而来的会有种明显的空虚感和缺乏成就感。2017年有一篇关于这方面的论文，名为《作为心理健康预测指标的真实性》，它调查了706名学生，发现那些践行真实生活、能说出自己五个个人价值观的人，报告称他们不那么容易被外部影响左右。他们更快乐，对生活更满意，
because they just had less noise around whether what they were doing was right. Two more impacts of this, but I'll keep them short and sweet, because I want to mainly focus on the solutions. A fear of criticism or rejection specifically. It also might prevent us from taking risks, embracing opportunities, which I think is something that is essential during this decade. And finally, there's been evidence to suggest that it may mean
因为他们周围关于他们所做的事情是否正确的噪音更少了。关于这点的另外两个影响，但我会把它们说得简短而贴切，因为我想把重点放在解决方案上。对批评或拒绝的明确恐惧。它还可能阻止我们承担风险、拥抱机遇，我认为这是在这个十年中至关重要的事情。最后，有证据表明这可能意味着
we actually make worse decisions. So we either don't make a decision or when we do, it's not the one we actually want, because we're making decisions that don't align with previously expressed goals. or desires, and we second-guess ourselves. And it kind of feels like we're being guided by two separate and competing forces. What we want and what others think we want. And I imagine it like a tug of war where both sides is equally strong.
我们实际上做出了更糟糕的决定。所以我们要么不做决定，要么一旦做了决定，也不是我们真正想要的决定，因为我们做出的决定与之前表达的目标或愿望不一致，并且我们会自我怀疑。而且感觉就像我们被两个独立的、相互竞争的力量所引导。我们想要的和别人认为我们想要的。我把它想象成一场双方力量均等的拔河比赛。
So the thing in the middle, which is you, remains stagnant. There was a 2012 article, another one that I found published in the Journal of Human Behavior and Human Decision Making. And it also examined what happens when we let others not just dictate, but make decisions for us through their opinions and it turns out that when we follow what someone else thinks we can do we often end up a lot less happy because often they don't choose without interests in mind they choose what they think is best based on their philosophies based on their expectations of us and our happiness and
所以中间的那个东西，也就是你，仍然停滞不前。2012年还有另一篇文章，我发现发表在《人类行为与人类决策》杂志上。它还研究了当我们通过别人的意见让别人不仅发号施令，而且为我们做决定时会发生什么，事实证明，当我们顺从别人的想法去做我们可以做的事情时，我们往往最终会变得不那么快乐，因为通常他们做选择时并没有把利益放在心上，他们根据自己的哲学、根据他们对我们的期望来选择他们认为最好的，而我们的幸福和
their appreciation of our values and what we want just doesn't matter to them as much we know ourselves I want you to remember, you know who you are. You have been with you since the beginning. So we have to learn to trust that we will be okay if people don't like us. And if we don't do things the way that they want us to do them. And there is a real power in that, but there is also real genuine peace. You know, I'm saying this is someone who used to be so worried about it, especially when I was in
他们对我们的价值观以及我们想要什么的赞赏对他们来说并不那么重要，我们了解自己，我希望你记住，你知道你是谁。你从一开始就一直和自己在一起。所以我们必须学会相信，如果人们不喜欢我们，我们也会没事的。如果我们做事的方式不符合他们的预期，我们也会没事的。这其中蕴含着真正的力量，但也有着真正纯粹的平静。你知道，我是作为一个曾经为此深感担忧的人在说这些，特别是在我上
uni. I just was changing myself constantly based on who I was around and I never knew who I was ever. So how do we move past that instinct even when it feels impossible? What does the psychology tell us about rewiring our opinions and our attitude towards ourselves? Well, we are going to talk about all of that and so much more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
大学的时候。我只是根据我周围的人不断地改变自己，我从来都不知道自己是谁。那么，当这种本能感觉不可逾越时，我们该如何超越它呢？心理学告诉我们关于重塑我们的意见和对自己的态度有哪些启示？好吧，我们将在短暂的休息后讨论所有这些以及更多内容。2%。那是坐自动扶梯时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健康和建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。这就是IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方的T-W-O-Persent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of Congress.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在播客《Look Back at it》中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析事情的经过，并试图理解我们是如何熬过这一关的。其中包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·hill的访谈，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。要我说清楚，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为国会。
crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
快克。我随时准备谈论快克，但只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始发现有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说更重要了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
是的。对我和美国历史上的黑人来说，这是最重要的一年之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听look back at it。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，
Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession
我在说。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了
of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth?
那样东西。我们却仍在追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的比赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在地球上时做一个好人很重要？
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。这是两个不同信任层次。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《learn the hard way》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。
Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
打开你免费的Iheart radio应用程序。搜索learn the hard way并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了长达数年的诉讼战来证明真相。你对某人伪造了这特定测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支网络侦探大队来破案。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
我想让人们看到他们的税款都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯利，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《爱的陷阱》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因涉嫌欺诈被起诉。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
With all that we're discussing today, I really don't want it to come off like I'm dismissing the sting of being disliked and that I'm saying that it's not painful because it is. Feeling rejected, criticized, even hated, it's an incredibly painful experience. Specifically, it elicits social pain. and I wouldn't blame anyone for wanting to avoid that if they could. So if you are someone who is struggling with it, I'm not sitting here being like, be stronger, you're just so weak-willed, grow a spine, absolutely not, because I know how insidious that feels like, that urge to be validated by others feels like.
结合我们今天讨论的所有内容，我真的不想让它听起来像是在淡化被人讨厌的痛苦，或者说它不痛苦，因为它的确很痛苦。感到被拒绝、被批评，甚至被讨厌，这是一种极其痛苦的体验。具体来说，它引发了社会痛苦，如果有人想避开这一点，我不会责怪任何人。所以如果你是一个正在为此苦苦挣扎的人，我不会坐在这里说，坚强点，你太软弱了，拿出点骨气来，绝对不会，因为我知道那种感觉有多么阴险，那种被他人验证的冲动感觉有多真实。
It's just so innate in us, and I really struggle with it at times, especially when I get troll comments or negative comments, they're not something that I easily forget, even if I try really hard. So it would be facetious to suggest that it doesn't cross my mind or that I'm perfect or there is any one person who doesn't care. Actually, I think someone who doesn't care at all would probably have a slight problem because there are times when you should really consider what other people think and feel about a situation.
它在我们身上是如此与生俱来，我有时也确实为此苦苦挣扎，尤其是当我收到喷子评论或负面评论时，它们不是我能轻易忘记的，即使我非常努力地去忘记。因此，如果暗示它没有掠过我的脑海，或者暗示我是完美的，或者暗示没有任何一个人不在乎，那就太虚伪了。事实上，我认为一个完全不在乎的人可能会有点问题，因为有些时候，你真的应该考虑别人对某种情况的想法和感受。
That's how we experience empathy. So not caring at all. it's also not a great thing but what i would like to remind myself and you as well is that people who think truly negative things about others and who then go on to express them i wouldn't want to live even a day not alone like you know not even in their mind in their shoes i wouldn't want their life So why in the world would I let them dictate mine? It would be a very dark place to live inside the mind of someone who brings that kind of negativity to the world, who says those things, let alone thinks them. It would be a very hard life to be someone who deliberately tries to tear others down.
这就是我们体验同理心的方式。所以完全不在乎，也不是一件好事，但我想要提醒我自己以及你的是，那些对别人抱有真正负面想法并继续表达出来的人，我甚至不想过哪怕一天不孤单的生活，你知道的，甚至不在他们的脑海里，不在他们的鞋子里，我不会想要他们的生活。所以我到底为什么要让他们来左右我的生活呢？生活在这样一个人的内心世界里将会是一个非常黑暗的地方，他们给世界带来这种消极情绪，说出这些话，更不用说去想它们了。作为一个刻意试图贬低他人的人，生活将会是非常艰难的。
And if they are thinking all of those things about others, what happens when they turn the spotlight, back onto themselves. You have probably heard of the saying, hurt people, hurt people. There is a lot more truth to that than you may know. The study you support that people who criticize others are often more insecure than you or I. So there was a really amazing paper in 2018 on ostracism and aggression. So aggression particularly online. And it found that people who have felt excluded or rejected in the past, they are more likely. to express negativity and aggression, particularly verbal aggression towards others. And the people they most turn this hatred towards is those they feel have a higher status than them.
如果他们对别人有所有这些想法，当他们把聚光灯转回到自己身上时会发生什么。你可能听说过这样一句话：受过伤害的人会伤害别人。这其中包含的真理比你想象的要多。支持这一点的研究表明，批评他人的人往往比你我更缺乏安全感。因此，2018年有一篇关于排外和攻击行为的非常精彩的论文。特别是网络攻击。研究发现，过去感到被排挤或拒绝的人更有可能表现出负面情绪和攻击性，尤其是对他人的言语攻击。他们最常将这种仇恨倾注在那些他们觉得地位比自己高的人身上。
It's why the age old saying is often proven to be true. People always hate those who they think are doing better than them. And you want to know why? You want to know why they do that. It's because if they can't be where you are, the second best option for you, for them is for you to join them where they are. If they, you know, can pull you down to their level, they can still feel like they've won because at least you're not ahead of them, making them feel any more insecure than they already feel. So these groups of people, these ultimate
这就是为什么那句老话往往被证明是正确的。人们总是讨厌那些他们认为比自己过得好的人。你想知道为什么吗？你想知道他们为什么这样做吗？这是因为如果他们不能到达你所在的地方，对你来说、对他们来说的第二选择就是让你加入他们所在的水平。如果他们，你知道的，能把你拉到他们的水平，他们仍然会觉得自己赢了，因为至少你没有跑在他们前面，让他们感到比已经感到的更没有安全感。所以这群人，这些终极
haters, they make up their own class. I like to call them the insecure critics. But if we want to dive even further into the research, you would also find that the majority of the people, they're time, the average Joe, most people aren't really thinking about you at all. So this was revealed in a study by three social psychologists. Their names were Gus Gooney, Erica Boothie and Mariana Lee, and they did their research on what they call the thought gap. And this explains how we tend to think that we take up more space in someone else's mind than we do. And the reason we think that, the reason we have this thought gap is because we only have direct access to our own thoughts. And what are we thinking about more than anything else? We're thinking about ourselves.
喷子，他们自成一派。我喜欢称他们为缺乏安全感的评论家。但如果我们想更深入地研究这项研究，你也会发现大多数人，他们的大部分时间，普通大众，其实根本没有在想你。这是三位社会心理学家的一项研究揭示的。他们的名字是加斯·古尼、埃里克·布西和玛丽安娜·李，他们对他们所谓的“思维差距”进行了研究。这解释了为什么我们倾向于认为我们在别人的脑海中占用的空间比实际要多。我们之所以这么想，我们之所以有这种思维差距，是因为我们只能直接接触到我们自己的思想。我们想得最多的又是什么呢？我们在想我们自己。
So we naturally, subconsciously, without knowing it, assume that other people must be thinking about us too. And they must be thinking the same thoughts. They're on the same page as us. Therefore, we overestimate how much they truly notice. It's a common cognitive and social bias that brings about a lot of implicit self-scrutiny. And there's even more research on this as well. And it shows that we actually tend to implant our own securities onto others' thoughts. And we assume that they can see all the things that only we can notice. You may also know this as the spotlight effect. And I had this experience with a friend recently where this was very clear to me. We were looking through pictures from her birthday party and there was this truly beautiful photo of her like smiling with a bunch
所以我们很自然地、潜意识地、不知不觉地假设别人也一定在想我们。而且他们一定有相同的想法。他们和我们在同一页上。因此，我们高估了他们真正注意到的程度。这是一种常见的认知和社会偏见，会带来大量的内隐自我审视。关于这一点还有更多的研究。它表明，我们实际上倾向于将自己的不安全感强加给别人的想法。我们假设他们能看到所有只有我们自己才能注意到的事情。你可能也知道这叫聚光灯效应。我最近和一位朋友有过这样的经历，这对我来说非常清楚。我们翻看她生日派对的照片，有一张她对着镜头笑得很灿烂的照片，周围有一群人
of our friends her hair was like impeccable she had a beautiful outfit on her makeup was like stunning everything i literally saw the photo and gasped because i was like you just look so great and she immediately was like oh my god no can't you see my double chin and can't you see my arms like don't let anyone post that and of course i hadn't noticed a single one of these features because others don't search for our insecurities the way that we do. And I want to just say that one more time, other people do not search for our insecurities the way that we do. So these are just a few reminders if you're in a spiral
我们的一个朋友，她的发型简直无可挑剔，穿着一身漂亮的衣服，妆容也美得惊艳。我一看到那张照片就倒吸了一口气，因为我觉得她看起来太棒了。而她立刻就说：“噢，天哪，不，难道你没看到我的双下巴吗？难道你没看到我的胳膊吗？别让任何人发这张照片。”当然，我根本没有注意到这些特征中的任何一个，因为别人不会像我们自己那样去寻找我们的不安全感。我想再重复一遍，别人不会像我们自己那样去寻找我们的不安全感。所以，如果你正处于焦虑的漩涡中，这些只是一些提醒
or you feel bombarded by imaginary or real judgments from those around you. Let's move on to some more practical tips, though. My first big tip if you struggle with caring too much about what other people think, other people think, is I want you to make an opinion hierarchy or rank the kind of opinions that you are likely to encounter. So at the bottom of your ladder, at the bottom of your scale, it should be complete strangers. Complete strangers, their opinions do not matter. They have no clue who you are. They really aren't invested in you as a person. They don't care about your growth. Your existence means very little to them. So their opinion ranks on the bottom. They are
或者你觉得自己被周围人想象中或现实中的评判狂轰滥炸。不过，让我们转向一些更实际的建议吧。如果你经常纠结于太在意别人的看法，我的第一个重要建议是：建立一个观点层级，或者把你可能会遇到的各种观点进行排名。所以，在你的阶梯底部，在你的量表的底部，应该是完全陌生的人。完全陌生的人，他们的意见一点也不重要。他们根本不知道你是谁。他们对你这个人其实并没有投入什么情感。他们不在乎你的成长。你的存在对他们来说微不足道。所以他们的意见排在最底部。他们
more likely to care about what you can do for them and how making you feel bad can make them feel better than they are to actually want what's best for you. The second tier is acquaintances, then it's colleagues, then it's friends, then we have the silver circle, close friends. I'm talking friends that are honorary family members. And then finally also in that silver circle, it's family members who trust and also your partner might be included here. as well. That's the inner sanctum. That's the silver circle though. We also have the gold circle. Who is left to belong in the gold circle? It's you. You and you only. I want you to draw out this diagram or this image, however you see it in your mind. I want you to draw it out. Put it on your mirror,
更关心你能为他们做些什么，以及让你感觉糟糕如何能让他们感觉更好，而不是真正想要对你最好的东西。第二层是熟人，然后是同事，接着是朋友，再然后是银色圈子，也就是挚友。我指的是那些名誉家庭成员级别的死党。最后，同样在这个银色圈子里，还有那些值得信任的家庭成员，你的伴侣也可能会被包含在内。这就是核心腹地。不过，除了银色圈子，我们还有金色圈子。谁有资格属于金色圈子呢？是你。只有你，也唯有你。我希望你画出这个图表或这幅画面，无论你在脑海中如何想象它。我希望你把它画出来。把它贴在你的镜子上，
somewhere in your car, front page of your diary, whatever it is, as a reminder of how other people's judgments rank compared to your own. I think the big problem with spending too much time thinking about the thoughts of others is that we end up becoming detached or disconnected from our own opinion about something, including ourselves. So our intuition becomes injured because we're letting too many voices interrupt. So what I really want you to do is opposite to what your gut feeling is saying. And I want you to actually let yourself acknowledge.
贴在你的车里某处、日记的首页，无论是什么地方，以此提醒自己，与你自己的判断相比，别人的判断排在什么位置。我认为，花太多时间去揣摩别人的想法，其最大的问题在于，我们最终会与自己对某件事（包括对我们自己）的看法产生脱节或断开连接。因此，由于我们让太多的杂音插进来，我们的直觉受到了损害。所以我真正希望你做的，是与你的直觉感受相反的事情。我希望你真正让自己去承认
the opinions of others, let yourself really lean in, let yourself really absorb it, don't ignore it, and then ask yourself, okay, but what do I think? All of this aside, I've listened, I've given you your time, I've listened. Now what is my opinion? And which one is going to make me happier to listen to? Think about it in the context of an outfit. That's a very simple enough example. You might ask all your friends, what do you think? What do you think about this look? 50% of them might say, I hate it. 25% say, yeah, it's fine.
别人的观点，让自己真正去倾听、去吸收，不要忽视它，然后问问自己：“好吧，那我怎么想？”抛开这一切，我已经听了，我已经给了你时间，我也倾听了。现在我的看法是什么？哪一种看法会让我听了之后更快乐？把它放在一套衣服的语境下来考虑。这是一个足够简单的例子。你可能会问你所有的朋友：“你们觉得怎么样？你们觉得这身造型怎么样？”50%的人可能会说：“我讨厌它。”25%的人说：“嗯，还行。”
25% say it's really beautiful. I like it. Let those perspectives sink in and then turn around and say, all right, time to ask myself. What's my opinion? And based on that hierarchy, what do I choose to do here? This also is important because it allows yourself to be exposed to just, judgment without letting it, you know, kind of penetrate the armor, knowing that you can listen
25%的人说：“真的很好看。我很喜欢。”让这些观点沉淀下来，然后转过身说：“好了，是时候问问我自己了。我的看法是什么？根据那个层级，我在这里选择怎么做？”这也同样重要，因为它能让你直面评判，而又不会让它穿透你的铠甲，让你知道你可以倾听
and not be hurt by it. These opinions through this process will start to feel less and less important to you as your opinion and intuition become louder and louder and louder until you don't need to ask for validation about not just outfit choices, but everything else in your life. That's really what the people who you see who are just crushing it are doing. There's people you see who are so authentic and true to themselves and they have great style and they've always focused on something and they're deeply committed and they let mean things bounce off them. They have in some ways done this exercise in the past, even if they don't realize it. Second, if you want to start turning inwards for validation rather than outwards, it's really important to strengthen your
并且不会受到它的伤害。通过这个过程，这些意见对你而言会变得越来越不重要，而你的观点和直觉会变得越来越响亮、越来越坚定，直到你不再需要为不仅是穿衣搭配，还有你生活中的方方面面去寻求认可。这其实正是那些你所看到的、正过得风生水起的人们在做的事情。你会看到有些人是如此真实、忠于自我，他们有着极佳的品味，他们总是专注于某事并且深度投入，他们能让刻薄的言论从自己身上弹开。他们在某种程度上过去就已经做过这个练习了，即使他们自己并没有意识到。其次，如果你想开始向内寻求认可而不是向外，那么强化你的
sense of self and your identity and make sure you remind yourself what is important to me. I'm going to ask you right now, what are three things that are really important to you right now? I'll give you a few seconds. The thing is, if you don't know, if you can't name them, I think your identity needs a few renovations, it needs a few additions. You want to have that strong, personal, internal home that you can come back to. Also, I think focus on being a good, authentic person rather than just an agreeable person. You can be someone who is kind, self-assured, who has amazing things going for them, and also who can stick up for themselves. You can be someone who still, you know, listens to their family, listens to their friends, does ask for advice and does seek counsel. But also, when they
自我意识和认同感，并确保提醒自己什么对我是重要的，这非常重要。我现在就要问你，此时此刻对你真正重要的三件事是什么？我给你几秒钟时间。关键是，如果你不知道，如果你说不出它们的名字，我认为你的认同感需要做一些翻新，需要做一些补充。你希望拥有那个强大、个人化的、内在的家，让你能够随时回归。另外，我认为我们要专注于做一个善良、真实的自己，而不仅仅是一个随和的人。你可以是一个善良、自信、有着美好事物眷顾，同时也能够坚持自我的人。你可以是一个依然，你知道的，听取家人意见、听取朋友意见、会寻求建议和咨询的人。但同时，当他们
have a gut feeling, when they have an instinct, when they like something, they know how to act on it. really what it comes down to is don't let yourself doubt yourself any further. Like don't do that to yourself. Don't, you know, second guess yourself. Don't feel like, again, the opinion of a stranger is more worthwhile than yours. Instead, I want you to commit deeply and without compromise to what you want and what you want to do and what you care about. And make sure that if someone asked you, what do you care about, you would know how to answer. You'd know how to respond. Make an investment in yourself by choosing one goal, one hobby,
有一种直觉、有一种本能、当他们喜欢某样东西时，他们知道该如何付诸行动。这归根结底其实就是：不要再让自己怀疑自己了。不要对自己做这种事。不要，你知道的，去二次猜测自己。不要觉得，再次强调，一个陌生人的看法比你的更有价值。相反，我希望你毫无保留、坚定不移地投入到你想要的东西、你想做的事情以及你在乎的事情中去。并确保如果有人问你“你在乎什么？”，你懂得如何回答。你懂得如何回应。通过选择一个目标、一个爱好来对自己进行投资，
one passion you want to work at and make yourself a good life full of things that you care about way more than others and that you could continue to do even if the world hated it. You know, I just don't let your life just be, you know, work, come home, watch TV, order takeaway, maybe hang out with your friends on the weekend and let everyone else stick. dictate what you do. I just don't think that's a strong foundation for a good life. I don't think it's a strong foundation for a good sense of self and it will make you easily swayed. It will make you feel like you don't know how to do things. You don't know what you want. You don't know what you like. But are you giving yourself enough new experiences and external stimulus and excitement to actually
一个你想为之努力的激情所在，让自己过上充实的生活，里面充满那些远比别人的看法更重要的事物，即使全世界都讨厌它，你也能继续做下去。你知道，我只是不希望你的生活仅仅是，你知道的，工作、回家、看电视、点外卖，周末可能和朋友闲逛，然后让其他人来决定你该做什么。我只是认为这不是美好生活的坚实基础。我认为它不是塑造良好自我意识的坚实基础，这会让你轻易动摇。这会让你觉得你不知道该怎么做事。你不知道自己想要什么。你不知道自己喜欢什么。但是，你是否给自己足够的新体验、外部刺激和兴奋感，来真正
give yourself the chance to know what you want? Finally, finally. I will. want you to adopt the 555 rule. Basically, the 555 rule looks at other people's opinions or thoughts of you. I don't know. I keep using the item like your outfit one a lot. It just seems easy. You know, you're not fit enough. You don't look the way. You're not attractive. You don't look how I want you to look. You're never going to be successful. I don't believe in you. Whatever it is. That someone has told you at some point in your life. It looks at the opinions of others and it says, will it matter in five days? Will it matter in five months?
给自己一个了解自己想要什么的机会？最后，最后。我想要你们采用“555法则”。基本上，“555法则”审视的是其他人对你的看法或想法。我不知道，我一直频繁地用“你的穿着”这个例子。它似乎很简单。你知道，“你不够苗条”、“你看上去不对劲”、“你没有吸引力”、“你看起来不像我希望的那样”、“你永远不会成功”、“我不相信你”。无论是什么。你在人生的某个阶段被别人这样说过。它审视着他人的观点，然后问道：这在五天后还重要吗？这在五个月后还重要吗？
Will it matter in five years? And crucially, will it matter if I don't listen? Obviously, if you take something deeply to heart, it will still matter in five years. But if you just treat someone's opinion with complete neutrality, will it matter? And the rule of five says that the only things we should concern ourselves with are issues or problems that will still be impacting us in five years time.
这在五年后还重要吗？至关重要的是，如果我不听取它，它还重要吗？很显然，如果你把某些事情深深记在心里，它在五年后依然会重要。但如果你只是以完全中立的态度对待某个人的观点，它还重要吗？“五年法则”指出，我们唯一应该关注的事情，是那些在五年后仍将对我们产生影响的问题或困难。
So what I'm talking about there is genuine feedback that someone is giving you in good faith to help you improve your life. That is what will matter in five years time. A family member saying, you know, I don't think like this way of going about your life is harming you. That's an opinion you should listen to. Or a boss saying, hey, if you have so much potential, but if you don't do this thing, if you don't fix this thing, if you don't expand this part of yourself more, you won't get ahead.
所以我所说的是别人出于善意给你的真正反馈，用来帮助你改善生活。那才是五年后仍然重要的事情。比如家庭成员说：“你知道，我觉得你这种生活方式正在伤害你。”这是一个你应该听取的意见。或者老板说：“嘿，你很有潜力，但如果你不这样做，如果你不改正这一点，如果你不更多地拓展自己的这一面，你就无法取得成功。”
That's an opinion you should listen to. But, you know, mean, snarky criticism from a co-worker, strange look from lady on train, someone on the internet trolling you, opinion of old friend from high school, that's not five-year-worthy. So they can be acknowledged and swiftly dismissed. My last tip, and it does kind of link to that one as well, is choose your people wisely. choose people to be around you who you aspire to be like, who respect you, who you respect, who will help you course correct, but also who encourage you rather than bring you down. There is no backhanded compliments, there is no worrying what they'll think. We all know the experience of having a friend who you can never quite tell whether they want to see you fail or whether they want to build you up or whether they just want to.
这是一个你应该听取的意见。但是，你知道的，来自同事尖酸刻薄的批评、火车上某个女士的奇怪眼神、互联网上某个喷子的网暴、高中老朋友的看法——这些可不值得花上五年的时间去在意。所以这些都可以被认可并迅速打发掉。我的最后一个建议，它其实也和那条有点联系：明智地选择与什么人交往。选择那些你渴望成为的人、尊重你的人、你尊重的人、会帮你纠正航向，并且是鼓励你而不是打击你的人在身边。这里没有阴阳怪气的恭维，也不用担心他们会怎么想。我们都经历过这样的情况：某个朋友，你永远无法确切弄清楚他们是希望看到你失败，还是希望看到你成长，亦或是他们只是想要
want something from you. Like, there is some people who are like that. And again, I want to remind you, they deserve love, they deserve respect, because they're probably going through it themselves. Like, if your existence brings out that insecurity in them, it's because they were already insecure. So really choose people who you know are going to elevate you, who will never make you question what it is about you that is authentic and pure and true to you. And I think that that makes you more confident in your own decisions, more confident in who you are, because you're not worried about the immediate threat or possibility of upsetting someone or disappointing someone.
从你身上得到什么。真的，有些人就是这样的。再次声明，我想提醒你，他们值得被爱，值得被尊重，因为他们可能自己也在经历这些。如果你的一存在激发了他们心中的那种不安全感，那是因为他们本来就已经很不安全了。所以，一定要选择那些你知道会提升你的人，那些永远不会让你去质疑自己身上到底什么是真实、纯粹、忠于自我的人。我认为这会让你对自己的决定更加自信，对你是谁更加自信，因为你不用担心去惹恼某人或让某人失望的这种即时威胁或可能性。
So those are just some of the tips that I wanted to give you today. Honestly, I could give you millions more. Everyone else, everyone really has their own ways of thinking about it. Some people like to imagine a big giant orb that surrounds them that other people's opinions bounce off of. Some people like to get quite existential with it. They like to, you know, really focus on the fact that we get one life. No one's going to remember you and that is actually a really helpful thought and it's quite nice to imagine the kind of liberty and peace and freedom that comes with no one really ever being able to remember your actions. So it is really about
所以这些就是我今天想给你们的一些建议。老实说，我还可以给你们成千上万条。每个人，真的每个人都有自己的一套思考方式。有些人喜欢想象一个巨大的、环绕着自己的能量球，别人的意见撞到它就会弹开。有些人喜欢用相当存在主义的方式来看待它。他们喜欢，你知道的，真正专注于这样一个事实：我们只有一生。没有人会记住你，这其实是一个非常有帮助的想法，而且想象一下那种伴随着“没有人会真正永远记住你的行为”而来的自由、平静和解放，感觉真的很好。所以这其实是关于
finding out what works for you. But at the end of the day, really building up the parts of you that are going to be strong and that are going to be foundations for you, no matter what anyone else thinks, feels, says, believes, whatever it is. So I hope you enjoyed this episode. Please, if you've made it this far, leave a little cloud emoji in the comment section and leave your thoughts on what you learned from this episode whether you think you can apply it to your own life. I love seeing how far people get and it's always really cute to be like, oh, hello, my finishes, my people who are committed to the episode. So again, thank you for listening. Also, if you haven't yet listened to Mantra, if you liked this episode, I really think you're going to like Mantra. It's basically
找出什么对你有效。但归根结底，真正去建立你身上那些将变得强大、将成为你人生基石的部分，无论其他人怎么想、怎么感受、怎么说、怎么相信，无论是什么。所以我希望你喜欢这一集。求求你了，如果你听到了这里，请在评论区留下一个小云朵表情符号，并留下你对从这一集中学到了什么的想法，以及你认为是否可以将其应用到你自己的生活中。我喜欢看大家能听到多远，而且看到像“哦，你好，我的完播者们，我的那些致力于这一集的忠实听众们”总是觉得非常可爱。所以再次感谢大家的收听。另外，如果你还没有听过《Mantra》，如果你喜欢这一集，我真的觉得你会喜欢《Mantra》。它基本上是
pep talks for your week that can ground you. So I'll leave a link in the description. Make sure you were following along on Instagram at That Psychology podcast. We do episode summaries. We do polls all the time. I ask you for your opinions on episodes. So it'd be great to see you over there. And until next time, stay safe. Be kind and above all else. Be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men. experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
给你一周的心灵加油站，能让你脚踏实地。所以我会在简介里留一个链接。确保在 Instagram 上关注 @That Psychology podcast。我们会做每集摘要。我们一直都在做民意调查。我会就每一集征求你们的意见。所以很高兴能在那里见到你们。下次见之前，注意安全，保持善良，最重要的是，对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会聊到。嘿，最近怎么样，伙计们？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games 主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都绝对不安全进行的诚实对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct?
有多少男人穿着一身铠甲。它向世界发出信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。请在 AHA Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吧？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a love trapped podcast on the EyeHour Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 IHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听播客《Love Trapped》。2%。这是有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
我剖析了心理坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即 TWO。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. on the iHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜们。收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。这是一个 iHeart 播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证真人。本集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。